the gunman suspected of carrying out the
deadliest attack on Jews in American
history is expected to appear in court
today as a tight-knit Pittsburgh
community mourns its lost thousands of
people gathered last night for an
emotional vigil to pay respects to the
11 people killed in Saturday's massacre
tributes to the victims are pouring in
from all around the world we are
learning more about their lives and
about the suspects history of hateful
views viana is leading our coverage from
Pittsburgh this morning we'll go to her
and our team of correspondents in just a
moment but first as Nora mentioned we
have breaking news from Indonesia a lion
air Boeing 737 max eight carrying 189
people crashed into the sea this morning
rescuers have located debris but they do
not expect to find any survivors the
flight took off from Jakarta and was
headed for an island off Sumatra this is
Indonesia's worst airline disaster since
2014 when an AirAsia plane crashed
killing 162 people Ben Tracy is
following developments from Beijing Ben
good morning good morning we don't yet
know what caused this crash but the CEO
of Lian air says that this plane did
have a technical issue on a previous
flight Sunday night it was then cleared
for takeoff Monday morning and 13
minutes into that flight it disappeared
from radar wreckage of Lion Air flight
10 was found near a fuel slick where the
plane went down along with passengers
belongings such as these smartphone
covers several bodies already appear to
have been recovered 189 people were on
board including three children when the
nearly brand-new Boeing 737 max plunged
into the Java Sea on Monday morning the
Lion Air flight took off from Jakarta's
Airport at 6:20 a.m. reaching an
altitude of 5,200 feet the skies were
clear but the pilot was granted a sudden
request to return to the airport two to
three minutes after takeoff the plane
then began descending at almost 400
miles per hour
it disappeared from radar nine miles
north of Jakarta's Coast worried family
members arrived at a crisis center
waiting for news of their loved ones and
hoping for a miracle Lyon air is
Indonesia's
youngest but largest airline their last
fatal accident was in 2004 when 25
people were killed in a dc9 that crashed
in heavy rain but the safety of
indonesian airlines has long been a
concern and they had been banned in
parts of the world after making great
strides to improve their safety record
europe lifted its ban on indonesian
carriers in june the u.s. lifted a
similar ban in 2016 this is the first
crash of the relatively new boeing 737
max in a statement boeing said it was
deeply saddened by the accident and
stands ready to provide technical
assistance to the accident investigation
now there's no word if there were any
Americans on board this Lion Air flight
Indonesian officials say that the
recovery effort will continue for at
least seven days but rough seas are
already making that difficult
go boy Ben Tracy reporting from Beijing
thank you